Ron DeSantis is planning to announce his
bid for president today that part is not
all that interesting everybody knew that
he was going to run the interesting part
is how he's choosing to do it Elon take
it away
so uh yes I
um
will be interviewing
Ron Santos and he has quite an
announcement to make
um and we'll be the first time that
something like this is happening on
social media and with the real-time
questions and answers uh no not scripted
DeSantis is going to announce his
presidential bid in a conversation with
Elon Musk on Twitter now if I were
running I would announce my campaign in
a conversation with Tom on MySpace or
perhaps with the Winklevoss twins on
zanga because I am a little more old
school but what DeSantis is doing it's a
great move
it's a great move for Twitter which
needs to make itself indispensable which
needs to become the Hub of conversation
or it's going to go bankrupt within a
year it's a great move for the DeSantis
Campaign which needs to innovate or else
it's going to lose because Trump is
currently up by 41 points nationally and
this is great news for American public
discourse which currently has only one
prominent medium that is not completely
tyrannically left-wing I'm Michael
knowlesis the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show very important
breaking news another
long-standing well-known American
company has gone gay
we are T-minus seven days out from the
beginning of everything being painted
rainbow
we I guess it's already really started
but we will get to that we will get to
the new
the new gay company in just a little bit
first though don't want to skip over
this Twitter stuff this is great great
news smart for DeSantis also because if
DeSantis just gives a conventional
campaign announcement one he's going to
be running a conventional campaign and
if he runs a conventional campaign he is
going to lose to Trump that is almost
guaranteed so he's got to run an
unconventional campaign if he holds a
conventional kind of press conference
the questions are going to be about
Trump that's not going to make DeSantis
look very good
he's he's got to mix it up a little bit
now does launching your campaign on
social media does that go too far
does that close you off from Boomer
voters from
not very online voters I don't know
maybe that's a little bit of the risk
here
but don't forget the the cable news host
who is
most beloved by an older conservative
audience is Tucker Carlson Tucker is
bringing his show to Twitter he's doing
that in part because of the constraints
imposed on him by cable news and by Fox
News in particular
but he's going to do it and the bet
there is I can bring my largely Boomer
audience over to social media but forget
about Ron DeSantis even forget about
Tucker Carlson for a second I've got
more important news which is that
we are going to Twitter we here at the
daily wire are bringing all of our shows
to Twitter
we're going to remain on YouTube we're
going to remain on Apple podcasts we're
obviously going to remain for our
members the Inner Circle over at Daily
wire plus that's going to be the
premiere outlook for the shows but we're
also now going to be airing our shows on
Twitter in part we are doing this
because our buddy Matt Walsh irritated
the YouTube overlords and so he was
demonetized on YouTube and he was
constrained he was forced to find other
outlets he put a show on Twitter and
it's worked out very well
so then
Jeremy the god king boring who's never
never seen an opportunity that he hasn't
taken in politics and in business and in
the media he said okay great
you Libs wanted to present us with a
problem well now we've
found a solution out of that and so
we're going to bring all of the shows to
Twitter and this is great news for Elon
too because this com Twitter company is
not on good footing it had been almost
running to the ground by the time that
Elon took over and now Elon saying okay
we're going to have a real place for
traditional American Standards of speech
in the country
and we're all moving to that we'll see
how it goes now meanwhile the libs are
very very upset by all of this
especially the DeSantis is running
Vanity Fair headlines sums it up report
Ron DeSantis will formally announce his
2024 bid with Elon Musk because
apparently David Duke wasn't available
Duke who's a guy who has not been
politically relevant in like 30 years
David Duke he's the symbol of racism and
DeSantis he's a racist
he's a Neo-Nazi
he's uh is good news for DeSantis to be
called all of these things if you are
not called to these things by the
Democrats you are not making any
meaningful attack on what they hold to
be sacred on all of the crazy live
policies if they're not calling you a
racist if they're not calling you a
phobe if they're not calling you a bigot
then you just don't matter to them and
so this is good great news for Ron
DeSantis great news for Elon Elon Musk
the most prominent African-American in
the entire world
they they have the audacity to compare
Elon Musk with David Duke a white
supremacist Neo-Nazi we have an update
on the neo-nazis
the attack from a couple of days ago you
remember that U-Haul at night drove in
to Lafayette Square hit a post and it
was a little bit weird because they
opened up the back of the U-Haul there's
not much in there there's just this one
really nicely pressed clean brand new
Nazi flag
and so of course it's being reported
the neo-nazis are taking over again we
need to clamp down on conservatives and
when this happened
I said I was a little bit skeptical
it's kind of weird the details didn't
really add up I thought it was pretty
lackluster in terms of spectacle
I didn't think there was really a Nazi
sitting in that truck and
I would appear to have been proven
correct we now know the identity of the
driver driving the Nazi truck with the
perfectly ironed placed swastika flag
for the press to take pictures of
his name
Sai varshith khandula
Sai varshith khandula does that sound
like a Neo-Nazi name to you
maybe if I say with a German accent yeah
she's
that no I don't think so I think he's a
subcontinental sort of fellow so you
might say okay
he's not a Neo-Nazi it's all a big
misunderstanding because the swastika is
an ancient Indian symbol so maybe they
just got their wires crossed or maybe I
don't know maybe it's something else
whatever it is all they found in this
truck backpack duct tape notebook with
Pages full of writing and this brand new
Nazi flag if you were skeptical of this
attack you are justified in your
skepticism you're Vindicated once again
once again an important reminder we all
need it from time to time when you see
these headlines elon's a Nazi
is a racist Trump he he extolled the
virtues of Hitler at Charlottesville or
whatever they said about him the Nazis
are attacking Lafayette Square it just
don't believe it
99.999999999999
of the time
it's fake it's not real remember the
last Nazi attack was a Hispanic guy yeah
when you want to educate yourself one
thing you can do is listen listen to
shows such as this that will show you
the side that the establishment media
will not another thing you can do a
little more formal is go check out Grand
Canyon University right now go to
gcu.edu are you ready to take the next
step in your education but struggling to
fit traditional classes into your busy
schedule Grand Canyon University's
online programs are designed to make
earning your degree easy and accessible
no matter your age or stage in life
whether you're a busy professional
looking to advance your career or a
stay-at-home mom or dad juggling family
responsibilities gcu's online courses
give you the flexibility that you need
to learn on your own terms I really love
GCU I visited the physical Campus of GCU
years ago it was one of my first college
speeches I ever gave
I was really impressed by all of the
students there and their seriousness and
these guys are so serious and their
education was so helpful to them that I
now work with two of them two of them
are my colleagues one at the daily wire
one at Young America's foundation so GCU
man they're really they're punching
above their weight and they will
specialize in helping you fit your
bachelor's Master's or doctoral degree
into your busy day from scholarships to
customize scheduling your graduation
team led by your own GCU counselor
provides you with the personal support
that you need to succeed why wait take
your education to the next level go to
gcu.edu gcu.edu
speaking of racial attacks
forget about the Nazi white supremacists
or I'm sorry forget about the Indian
Nazis and the hispanic white
supremacists
you've also got to
pay attention to the black faces of
white supremacy that of course would be
not just Larry Elder in California but
Clarence Thomas and Tim Scott the view
the white ladies of the view very very
upset
at that white supremacist Tim Scott
running for president
he's one of these guys who you know he's
like Clarence Thomas black Republican
who believes in pulling Yourself by your
bootstraps rather than to me
understanding the systemic racism that
African Americans face in this country
and other minorities he doesn't get it
neither does uh Clarence right and
that's why they're Republicans yeah
he doesn't get it now let me joy beija
I'm going to tell you all is almost like
a faucy voice well they're both from New
York I'm going to tell you about the
black experience in America because
Clarence Thomas
and Tim Scott they don't understand it
everyone's making fun of her for this
some people are feigning outrage some
people are genuinely offended and
everyone is mocking this idea that Joy
Behar is advancing that Tim Scott and
Clarence Thomas
could misunderstand the black experience
in America enjoy behar's defense
it's not totally absurd in principle in
this case it is
if this is absurd because Joy Behar is
totally out of touch and Clarence Thomas
and Tim Scott are far more closely
grounded to reality and they have a far
more accurate perception of the world
but it's not it's not totally out of the
question that
black people could not like black people
or something like that
black people could not like black
identity racial politics that's of
course not out of the question
saying about women who oppose feminism
is it absurd to suggest that some women
oppose feminism no the women who post
feminism have a far Keener perception of
reality
then the pro-feminism women
and they're still women and they
recognize the complementarity of the
sexes
and so they espouse a world view that is
contrary to the dominant liberal
worldview
but that's very possible
people's
views of reality moral reality physical
reality political reality
do not derive
inevitably from physical characteristics
they don't
and I fear sometimes the conservative
response to ridiculous babblings the
kind of which we just heard from Joy
Behar are to suggest that they are well
black men absolutely understand the
black experience in America and they're
by virtue of being black they totally
get it better than a white person does
that's not necessarily true
that's not you you don't need to
experience something directly to have an
understanding of it in fact sometimes
having a little bit of a remove having a
little bit of perspective can help the
reason that Tim Scott and Clarence
Thomas are right is because
not only do they have some experience
but they have highly attuned faculties
of reason and they perceive the world
correctly and they begin from correct
premises and they're just right they're
right because they're right because they
view the world correctly
they're not wrong because of the color
of their skin they're not right because
of the color of their skin
they're just right they're right because
they're on the right okay and it's a
it's a subtle distinction but we don't
want to take the bait from the libs and
fall into their their mistaken thinking
I'm just feeling very charitable today I
don't know what to say I'm trying to
give Libs the benefit of the doubt left
and right Kareen Jean-Pierre she's
getting raked over the coals because she
said Democrats don't have a spending
problem
from the White House Podium everybody
she was asked the question very directly
because we're in this debt ceiling fight
here's her answer
speak to McCarthy said yesterday uh in
front of the White House that the reason
why we are in this problem is because
every time Democrats wanted to make a
deal they want to make a deal about
spending more money so do you agree with
speaker McCarthy the Democrats have a
standing problem no
to it
no to it look um I'll say this uh the
president's budget reduces the deficit
as you as you know by nearly three
trillion dollars over 10 years right
this is a president that believes in
dealing with the deficit in a real way
that's on top of the 1.7 trillion
dollars that the president has been able
to reduce the deficit the last two years
so the president takes this very
seriously okay Democrats don't have a
spending problem and then she gives
these pretty weak and dubious numbers
the numbers which
almost certainly are not accurate and
the numbers which are deceptive anyway
because the spending has gotten so
insane in recent years that if you if
you dial the volume up to 75 and then
you take it back down to 65 but really
your volume should be on a one to ten
scale you could say well I reduce the
volume from the loudspeaker but it's
still insanely light it's still going to
blow out your eardrum right so
all of that is a little ridiculous
but to her point
the Democrats do not have a spending
problem
she's right
she's totally right
and I know conservatives are going to
pull their hair out over this and say
you're lying Karine Jean-Pierre how
could you possibly say such a thing she
could say such a thing because it's not
a problem to the Democrats it's the
point that Democrats don't have a
spending problem Democrats have a
spending solution Democrats solution is
we are coming up against a traditional
culture that we've done a very good job
of cracking and disassembling but
there's still a lot of common sense in
America and we haven't attained total
perfect cultural hegemony yet so how are
we going to do that we're going to wield
the power of the state in a
unprecedented way
and in order to wield the power of the
state we need a lot of money to do it
and that's going to have a double effect
because if we spend a lot of money
that's also going to weaken the order of
our society which is going to give us an
opportunity to take even more power and
so the way that we're going to get more
control over the culture is to spend an
insane amount of money in debt America
to her enemies and Pummel our political
opponents into submission
it's very bad it's a bad thing to happen
but it's intentional it's effective it's
a solution
when are the Democrats going to address
the spending problem never never they're
never going to do that that's what
they're there for they're there to wield
that kind of power
are we going to observe that and
acknowledge that and try to turn the
political situation to our advantage are
we going to say wow golly she's crazy
imagine if the shoe were on the other
foot imagine if the shoe on the other
foot is going to be the Epitaph on The
Headstone of conservatism
being so charitable to my political
opponents I want a cookie for this I
want an award for how charitable I'm
being I'm gonna I'm gonna take a
charitable read of politics all the way
to the extreme
project Veritas has a new undercover
report out it's an extremely disturbing
report they infiltrated a pedo ring
that's on the internet and they were
able to track down some of the people
who were participating in this pedo ring
people saying the most horrible horrific
dis Disturbed things you can imagine
trading in the most demonic kind of
images you can imagine some people then
going out and
acting out their extraordinarily
disordered desires on real kids
watch with your own
discretion you know I mean proceed with
caution I've got just a little clip here
which we've cleaned up it's still
basically acceptable for wholesome
viewing uh of of project Veritas going
in finding one of these guys and
interviewing him and here's what he has
to say
the first man Jonathan we found living
in New York in government subsidized
housing how's it going Jonathan yeah so
uh is your email e-l-8
Gmail okay this stuff is kind of come up
because he was like addicted to a point
yeah
um
so it's like I actually now limit his
internet's assets but he does have a
phone like he's been asking for a tablet
and a computer being insisted about it
and um well yeah I'd say well
um will he act upon it will he do what I
like
I don't think so we had a meeting on
Katrina treatment plans and he was like
they were talking about the amount of
porno he's watching he said I can't even
brush my teeth he can't even brush his
teeth and then he said I stopped and
then I I do what I need to do and I
watched her I said because I just came
from he said it's up with the focus so
that's when we decided to limit his
internet and we limit everything and he
said slowly he is in therapy not for
this week
overall they go on and they interview
this guy
who is just a husk of a man I mean his
brain has just been melted by
pornography he is just completely
addicted he he's he's living in
government housing his life has totally
falling apart
obviously this is awful it's great that
project Veritas is going in shedding a
light on this I think they got one of
these websites shut down they've
referred a lot of cases to prosecutors
unfortunately the prosecutors aren't
doing very much about it
I think in part because the prosecution
has gone soft on crime recently but also
there's just so much of this there's so
much to prosecute that they don't even
get to it that's a little bit
frustrating so project Veritas is shined
a light on that that's all great stuff
but when I
watch the guy be interviewed and then
the person we just heard from this guy's
government appointed landlord
I feel a great deal of pity
I feel a great deal of pity not just for
that guy for all of us for our whole
culture which is in the throes of vice
and addiction obviously with the weird
sex stuff but with everything forget
just the sex stuff with drugs with
constant stimulation from computers and
screens and social media even of a
non-pornographic variety with with an
obsession with stuff and consumerism and
food and just and everything we are so
addicted and concupiscent and
incontinent and unable to control our
base appetites that's a social problem
this guy
is the extreme of that it is hard to
imagine a more extreme crazy example
than this guy he can't brush his teeth
he's so addicted to porn to the most
disgusting horrific kind of porn you can
imagine that he can't take
20 seconds
to put some toothbray brush his teeth
really quick and go he can't do that
that's how addicted he is to me that is
a cautionary tale we've talked about
porn a lot recently because we had a
guest on to talk about how one of the
drivers of the transgender identity
movement all this Mania is pornography
which is ubiquitous and it's a
technological kind of problem that
Society has never dealt with before this
is a product of an increasingly
libertine political order but then just
the technological innovation of
high-speed internet so it's everywhere
people write in about this all the time
who say I'm addicted to pornography or I
see pornography everywhere it's all over
Society
I think that's the extreme of that and
so the value I see in the investigation
from Project Veritas is one you know I
hope I hope it can clean up some
criminal Enterprises I'm a little
skeptical the prosecution will do that
but two look at that guy
do you want to end up like that guy
because that's the logical conclusion of
indulging Vice
That's The Logical conclusion directly
of porn I guess but of all of it
drugs
slothfulness in your job
Pride gluttony
weird sex stuff The Logical conclusion
of that is that you will become a slave
to your addictions that you won't be
able to brush your teeth
and the the only other option is to be a
slave to righteousness
in in the gospel when Christ says my
yoke is easy and my burden is light some
people hear that and they hear that to
mean
there is no yoke there is no burden
to choosing God over evil that's not no
the yoke is easy and the burden is light
there is a yoke there is a burden
but it doesn't look like that it doesn't
look like I can't brush my teeth because
I'm so addicted to Vice
it looks like growing from Vice and
addiction into mere incontinence so you
you wanted you you want to do bad things
or you want to do good things in your
mind but you still do a lot of bad
things two continents which is you want
to do good things and you mostly can
control yourself to do the good things
to ultimately virtue of speaking with a
priest friend last night who said people
now they don't even think that virtue is
possible and you don't even need to be a
practicing Christian to understand this
this is a traditional idea this is just
going back to Good Old Uncle Aristotle
and others as well
but but if you don't practice those
habits of virtue you're going to
practice habits of Vice
and you're going to end up down the path
to that guy that's some of the most
important investigative journalism I've
seen in weeks and it has almost nothing
to do with the story itself has to do
with the Story of All of Us and how the
society is operating we had to talk
about this with people
when you want to talk to your friends
you got to check out pure talk right now
go to puretalk.com Knowles remember the
last time you got a free phone how'd it
start it started out great didn't it and
then came the Hefty activation fees the
four line requirements and of course
that binding contract Pure Talk is
giving you a free 5G Samsung Galaxy
phone without the feeling that you've
been duped when you switch to Pure
Talk's unlimited talk and text to data
plan that comes with a mobile hotspot
you will get a 5G Samsung Galaxy for
free that's right unlimited everything
at a fraction of the price of Verizon
ATT or T-Mobile and here's another thing
you will be on America's Most Dependable
5G Network how do I know I'm a customer
so make this switch to Pure Talk the
cell phone Wireless company I'm proud to
stand behind because they offer great
service and they are proud to stand
behind our mission at the daily wire
pure talks us-based customer service
team will help you make the switch in as
little as 10 minutes you can even keep
your own phone number it's just a great
company great service go to puretalk.com
Knowles for your free Samsung Galaxy
when you sign up for unlimited talk text
and unlimited data puretalk.com Knowles
Pure Talk Wireless for Americans by
Americans if you're looking for
something interesting to watch check out
our series what we saw hosted by
Storyteller Bill Whittle season one is
focused on Apollo 11 and now season two
of what we saw is in full swing in
episode 11
we continue on as a Fearless fighter
pilot breathes new life into discouraged
American aviators during the Vietnam War
as they defy outdated tactics and
execute a lightning fast surprise attack
shaping one of history's most remarkable
military operations
Bill makes you feel like you were there
witnessing history
hear this incredible story in this
week's episode of Cold War new episodes
of The Cold War come out every single
week but you've got to be a member to
see it go to dailywire.com Cold War to
start watching
speaking of cautionary tales
this headline from USA Today this takes
the cake
this Takes the absurdity Cake this is
more absurd than Vanity Fair calling
Elon Musk David Duke calling Ron
DeSantis a white supremacist
USA Today
black women looking for black sperm
donors struggle with harsh reality of
shortage
when Marta Shea Julian West and her wife
decided to become moms through in vitro
fertilization they knew they definitely
wanted black babies they just didn't
know how hard it would be
whatever laws we need to pass to make
that paragraph
unintelligible
or less intelligible than it already is
to make it implausible in society we
need those laws
a woman and her wife that is not that's
not real that is not a semantic a
semantically meaningful phrase that is
not the sort of thing that ought to be
culturally accepted or understood and it
certainly shouldn't be legal it's it's
meaningless you can't
someone cannot be her wife because
marriage necessarily involves sexual
difference that's the first part they
decided to become moms two women can't
simultaneously be the mom of one person
because people are created with a by a
mom and a dad you need both of those
things as these women realize which is
why they're trying to purchase sperm
from Men Who donate that sperm by
selling their progeny the prospect the
potential for progeny for money which is
extremely disordered and obviously
should be illegal and then they commit
an act that is immoral and should not be
encouraged by the culture or the state
and then the cherry on top is
they they don't want those defective
white babies or biracial babies they
want those good black babies and they're
very upset that they can't go to the
black baby store and buy a black baby
because there aren't enough black men
who are selling out their future progeny
and committing grave mortal sins
so that the banks can take the money and
sell the black babies
we were just mind blown says this lady
Marte Julian West
there are black lesbians they're black
queer people there are straight people
who have fertility issues there's just a
huge demand so it was insane I remember
feeling angry resentful and robbed she
feels robbed because she feels that she
is owed a baby not just any baby she can
get the baby even without marrying a man
but but she can't get this totally black
baby and she feels wrong she feels
entitled to it but of course when it
comes to procreation the only person who
can be said to have any rights
is the baby
babies have a right to a mother and a
father
babies have a right to be conceived
through the conjugal action of their
natural mother and father
people don't have a right to babies
babies are wonderful I got two babies
but not everyone gets to have a baby
some people struggle with infertility
some people choose not to get married
some people pursue other sexual desires
and they prioritize that over having a
family
and that's that it pays your tickets and
it takes your seats okay that's it
a lot of lack of black donors is nothing
new experts say
but an increased demand for them in
recent years has turned a small problem
into a big one causing families to wait
for years for the right donor
spend thousands of dollars in the
process and often make compromises
on the race of their children
compromises
you got to compromise
I know what the Epitaph of The Headstone
of conservatism says but
let's just take that Vanity Fair article
that called Elon Musk white supremacist
and Rhonda Sanders a white supremacist
and then imagine if Rhonda Santos and
Elon Musk said oh we had to compromise
on the race of art we wanted a beautiful
white baby but then we had to compromise
and he's a little bit black and we
didn't want that and we're angry about
this to quote this woman I want people
to be angry about this I know you know
we didn't want to have a black baby or
any part black we want a perfectly
pristine Aryan white baby but then we
had to settle for this uh partially
black baby because that was the sperm
that we were able to buy or whatever
could you imagine but we don't have to
imagine because
that's what we're hearing now except of
course
when the people who are angry are of a
favored race
rather than a disfavored race then this
is reported on quite sympathetically by
USA Today USA Today is not Vanity Fair
it's not slate magazine it's not
salon.com USA today's is the newspaper
that shows up at your at your door at a
hotel okay it's very mainstream paper
this is a very mainstreamed idea
how are we going to fix that are we
going to fix that by boycotting the
sperm banks or something we're going to
fix that by boycotting USA Today no we
can wield our cultural and Commercial
power the only way to fix that
is by wielding political power the only
way to fix that is by changing the law
and then enforcing the law and then
having the law be a teacher and changing
the culture in the process
what a media story and speaking of the
media I've got
I've got an article here from the
American profit the Associated Press
which used to be a little more Center
left now it has become a far extreme
left-wing news outlet and the AP is
reporting on John fetterman Senator John
fetterman who
had a stroke on the campaign Trail he
gets elected his brain is not working
properly he can't really speak there
were already news reports that he was
getting frustrated and he couldn't
understand what people were saying to
him and he couldn't do even the basic
jobs of a U.S senator
he then checked himself into a clinic
ostensibly for depression no one really
knows the details of this he gets out
some months later
he's been appearing at hearings you can
take a listen obviously things are not
working very well for him
is it a staggering the responsibility
that the the head of a bank could
literally could literally crash our
economy
astonishing that's like if you have I
mean like and and they also realize is
that that that now they have it's in the
guaranteed a guaranteed way to be saved
by again by no matter no matter how you
know so it's it's you know isn't it
appropriate that the those kinds of this
kind of control should be more stricter
okay it goes on it gets much worse
there's no need to play the whole clip
and humiliate him it's very sad that his
family and his
colleagues are allowing this to happen
if you've ever known a stroke victim
they need to recuperate and they don't
need to be on National Television in a
high stress job
unable to speak on television when their
job is to speak so how's the AP
reporting on this
back in hoodies and gym shorts John
fetterman tackles Senate life after
depression treatment
so he's been showing up he's wearing
hoodies and sneakers around the Senate
it's scandalous it's sad everyone knows
this guy is now well how are they
reporting on it
people close to fetterman say his
relaxed comfortable style is a sign that
the senator is making a robust recovery
after six weeks of inpatient treatment
at Walter Reed Medical Center oh yes the
fact that he can't speak and can't even
dress himself in most of the time in the
Senate that's a sign of how well he's
doing great leader great supreme leader
John Federman doing wonderful causes son
to rise in the morning more from North
Korean television coming up this would
make a North Korean news anchor blush
this kind of this would make
a Soviet apparatchic news editor in the
height of the USSR working for Pravda
blush it is so preposterous
he's setting a new dress code
jokes
Vermont Senator Peter Welch
he was struggling and now he's a joyful
person to be around
okay yep sure he's great he's great
never better wonderful supreme leader
nobody believes that the AP editors
don't believe that the people reading it
don't believe that John fetterman and
his family don't nobody believes that
but we are all supposed to live in lies
because we have a sclerotic and
incompetent ruling class
now some people are trying to see some
opportunity there so we're talking about
Ron DeSantis making his big announcement
today
Hillary Clinton
the Former Future president of the
United States Hillary Clinton
it's never never quite goes away she was
being interviewed about
the Democrat side of this election and
she was asked do voters have a right to
be concerned about Joe Biden's age and
senility her answer
why yes they do
well I mean it's a concern for anyone
um and we've had presidents who've
Fallen before who are a lot younger and
people didn't go into you know heart
palpitations
um but he his age is an issue and people
have every right to consider it
but you know he has this great saying
and and you know I think he's right you
know he you know don't judge him by
running against the almighty but against
the alternative and
I am you know of the camp that uh I
think
you know he's determined to run he has a
good record that three years ago people
would not have predicted would have
gotten done uh he doesn't get the credit
yet that he deserves for what is
happening out in the country in terms of
you know jobs and growth and and
planning for the future with chips and
other stuff
so I obviously hope he stays you know
very you know focused and able to uh
compete in the election because I think
he I think he can be re-elected and
that's what we should all hope for
not the most rousing endorsement is it
it was that a rally cry
he is determined to run
he has uh good record
and he will probably run
um
can I run yet can I or is there an
opening is there an opening for Hillary
do not count this woman out Joe Biden
doesn't know which end is up Joe Biden
has in recent years not met a flight of
stairs that hasn't proven a Monumental
challenge to him Joe Biden is past his
Prime and his prime was never all that
great there were lots of people waiting
in the wings obviously Buddha judge and
Kamala are trying to fight over who
jumps in if Biden falls down every
single day both of them are total jokes
they're going nowhere Gavin Newsom is
the serious candidate waiting in the
wings out there in California that's why
he's going on a national tour to run
against Ron DeSantis because they're the
two sort of Shadow candidates and then
there's Hillary do not count her out
when people want to make predictions
about the 2024 election a year and a
half out they say oh it's totally
Trump's done oh it's totally DeSantis
Trump is cooked oh it's totally this
it's totally that the only thing you can
expect in a presidential election is the
unexpected Hillary Clinton has wanted to
be president every single moment since
she was in her mother's womb back when
she was denying that she was even a
human being and Hillary Clinton has
never lost that desire it has only grown
greater and greater with age
do not be surprised if we see a Hillary
2024. speaking of disreputable New
Yorkers such as Hillary Clinton
little update to the Jordan Neely story
Jordan Neely he's the career criminal 42
plus arrests who was taken down by a
hero Marine on the New York subway when
he was threatening people he's the guy
who
punched an old woman a woman of a
certain age in the face give her black
eye broke her nose attacked another
senior citizen so the uncle of Jordan
Neely Christopher Neely was just
arrested this week
after officials had been searching for
him for a string of larcenies allegedly
and then he was trying to run from the
NYPD they recognized him he was caught
carrying credit cards from numerous
victims he was armed with a gravity
knife
a bad dude he was a bad dude still is a
bad dude they arrested him
in the spirit of Charity that I am
extending to all of the libs today
to Karine Jean-Pierre to even people in
the throes of the worst kinds of crimes
this helps to explain Jordan Neely
himself doesn't exonerate Jordanelle it
doesn't mean the Marine was wrong to
take him down the Marine was absolutely
right to take him down but it is a
reminder that no man is an island unto
himself entire of himself
this is something the libs get right
when the libs point out that we live in
society and we're not just atomized
individuals floating in outer space and
what we do actually does affect other
people conservatives have tended to deny
that on the economic front
and liberals have tended to deny that
fact on the social fronts they say
whatever I do man it doesn't affect you
I can I can be in a polyamorous throuple
with two dudes in a billy goat it's
total that doesn't affect you man get
your head out of my bedroom or whatever
and the conservatives said get your head
out of my wallet get your head out of my
bank account but that's that's not real
those are those are both false
conclusions that come from the false
premise of liberalism that we are
fundamentally individuals and we're not
we're social creatures had Jordan nearly
been raised in a normal environment in a
normal culture with a better family with
without criminals all around him I'm not
saying he would have turned out right he
might have turned out rotten even then
but he would have had a better chance
and so when we want to fix our problems
and all these individuals who are acting
crazy who are in the throes of all sorts
of Vice some of whom look like that guy
in the project Veritas video the way
that we're going to fix that is not just
by saying hey look at the man in the
mirror and pull yourself up by your
bootstraps there's a role for that
there's a place for that people should
take a hard look in the mirror where
people should get down on their knees
and pray and also we should do that as a
community because man is not just an
individual floating in outer space man
is the political animal
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Peter England
who says Democrats say that that oh it's
the North Carolina governor says we're
going to set education back a generation
dot dot dot so SAT scores will go up
that's so true when the libs whine and
complain about school choice and they
say Oh no you're going to set education
back a generation that would be a good
thing let's hope that we can set
education back two or three or four or
five generations then students might
actually read books
there there was a piece going around the
internet yesterday and it was from a
forward to the Odyssey by Homer
and this man was writing about a hundred
years ago maybe a little more than 100
years ago writing about how when he was
teaching school the school students who
were eight to twelve years old asked him
for a fun little treat if they could
read The Odyssey as a break from all
their much more rigorous work today
school children probably don't know what
the Odyssey is and they surely wouldn't
ask to read it they'd probably just ask
to watch cartoons in the classroom or
something like that
let's set education back 10 Generations
can you imagine what an educated Society
we would have okay we're a few days out
now
week out from Rainbow month so another
company has gone gay this is a
commercial actually from some years ago
I think it's about two years ago it's
just come back up though it has made it
and gone viral in the wake of
transheiser bush destroying the most
popular beer in America Bud Light
which company is it
this certainly would pain the founder of
this company
Ford Motor Company super duper gay take
it away Ford
commercial opens do not attempt to
recreate or reenact this scene and then
where it should have a warning label you
know the rating for like a movie it's
the pride flag that says progress rated
for progress
here we go we had two mud-soaked Ford
trucks
go baby one looking meaner than the next
they're off-roading
hard they're driving fast
driving through water
and the oh but then the water washed all
the mud away
and it's gay
the truck has been painted in some pink
with a rainbow on it which for virtually
all of human history was a sign a symbol
given by God of his Covenant with
mankind that he would never again
destroy the world in the flood now it
just symbolizes weird sex stuff and
pride the queen of all sins
and then what happens the rainbow truck
wins
so it's not just that the gay truck the
lgbtq the trans truck
is accepted
it's in the race it wins it has to win
the trans truck has got to win
probably now Ford would not make that
commercial
reason being that Bud Light has been
destroyed I'm not sure Bud Light can
ever recover formerly the most popular
beer in America I think transheiser Bush
destroyed that and they destroyed it in
part because they wanted to stand in the
middle of the road so they couldn't
totally embrace the Dylan Mulvaney beer
can but they also couldn't totally
disavow the Dylan Mulvaney beer can
because the the
audience the consumer base hated the
Dylan Mulvaney transcan but the investor
class the liberal establishment the
media the powers that be they love the
transcan
and they exert a lot of control over the
companies through things like ESG
through things like garm through all of
these International associations and
agreements
which say that if you want access to
advertising if you want access to
Capital you've got to tow this crazy
woke line and so Bud Light has been
wrecked by that
now some companies are trying to dial it
back a Target decided to hire a Satanist
to promote weird trans clothing lines to
all sorts of people there are children's
trans clothing lines there's been
backlash against that now Target
Executives reportedly are scrambling
Ford I assume is going to try to
suppress this commercial it ain't 2021
anymore what changed what changed here
is conservatives were able to Institute
an effective boycott of Bud Light it
just took it a little bit too far and
Frat Boys and construction workers
actually stood up and said no we're not
going to drink this stuff anymore and
furthermore Bud Light it became so
egregious that it became a meme so now
if you're at a bar you say like hey guys
what do you want to drink all right I'm
going to get I'm going to get some
Yingling maybe I'm gonna get some shots
of Jameson and then if you want to make
fun of your buddy you'll say and Johnny
over there I'm gonna get him a Bud Light
yeah take that Johnny I'm making fun of
you I'm calling you effeminate they'll
say I don't want a Bud Light don't give
me a Bud Light man come on and so it's
become a joke and it's very hard to
recover from being a joke I mean that's
that's really brutal same thing probably
happening to Ford here we've got to keep
up that pressure
Matt made this point he articulated it
directly but this has been the point
that has been building for months now
which is
we need to make
that symbol toxic the pride flag symbol
we need to make that toxic we need to
have
companies think twice about it everyone
was talking about the the Dylan Mulvaney
incident as being harmful to the Bud
Light brand that's true but more
importantly it was it was harmful to the
Dylan Mulvaney brand now now other
companies are going to think twice
before sponsoring Dylan Mulvaney because
they don't want to lose six billion
dollars in market cap in two days
that's what we got to do and then once
we make these things culturally toxic or
as we're making these symbols culturally
toxic we've got to bring in the Cavalry
we've got to come back in with more
political force to ban some of this
stuff
to say no we talked about it yesterday
with the sisters of Perpetual Indulgence
this anti-christian drag troupe that is
being honored by the LA Dodgers the LA
Dodgers are either going to exalt the
sisters of Perpetual Indulgence or
they're going to exalt the Carmelite
nuns they're going to exalt regular
normal Christian sisters they're either
going to exalt LGBT ISM Pride ISM or
Christianity it's going to have to be
one or the other they're conflicting
moral views and we are going to operate
According to some moral view which one's
it going to be
don't back down now the the progress
that conservatives have made on this
just between 2021 and 2023 the fact that
companies are trying to suppress these
videos now back off them that shows we
are winning keep pushing much much
harder
before we go Kathy hokel she's the
governor of New York Kathy hokel
has responded to the migrant crisis
which has been a disaster for Democrat
politicians you see even the liberal
Democrat Eric Adams in New York he's
saying we don't want this migration
crisis stop sending the buses here this
is evil this is awful we can't keep it
up we got to stop it we need Law and
Order here Kathy hokel the Democrat has
come in she's taking the side of the
illegal immigrants
you think about what we have open right
now
I know upstate
key where it starts to
there are over 5 000 farm jobs 5 000
farm jobs open as we speak
the cows don't wait to be milked the
plants need to be
maintained and harvested in a few months
the crops we have more than 5 000 food
service jobs right now
I'm a former waitress I made pizzas
chicken wings weighted tables clean
floors did pots and pans
doesn't take a lot of skill I was 15
years old
those jobs are available
four thousand openings for janitors
cleaners and housekeepers as I mentioned
the jobs for Farm Workers as well
so we're grateful that the Biden
Administration has instituted a new
border process starting with the
suspension of title 42 on May 11th we
all know that date well and that will
allow Asylum Seekers from other
countries to seek sponsorship and to
apply from their home countries and if
they don't they will be turned back so
that is a shift in policy which we hope
will be successful and mitigate the flow
of new arrivals here we want these
people to apply we want them to come
here though we got to have them do these
jobs it's good come on over here illegal
immigrants we want you what does this
mean this means that Kathy hokel
thinks that her is her bread is buttered
more by the political class than by the
people the people have made their
opinion on illegal immigration clear the
people have been pretty articulate
populism is doing just great okay
a lot of the liberal Elite institutions
are on the run but some politicians are
betting against the people against clear
majorities the vast majority of the
people think transgenderism is insane
the vast majority of the people don't
want their kids being taught critical
race Theory and and weird sex stuff in
schools the vast majority of the people
want to drastically reduce migration so
why are there some politicians who are
still supporting these things
some I guess have firm ideological
beliefs Kathy hokel's not one of those
people why are some of the convenience
Sway in the wind politicians still
supporting the unpopular policies
because they believe that the political
class can do more for them and more
against them than the people can so what
do we have to do we need to show that
people still have some power in this
country we need to wield our pocketbooks
we need to boycott we need to say no to
transheiser Bush we gotta say no to
Target we couldn't say no to and then we
also need to infiltrate that political
class
start wielding the state we've got to
convince the Kathy hokels of the world
the liberal establishment shill Joe
Biden empty suit hack politicians of the
world that there are going to be
consequences too that you can't
totally turn against the people in their
common sense and not face any
consequences you've got to crack that
ruling establishment now today's work
Wednesday baby we got a lot Mr Davies
assures me we have a very important
video today the show continues now daily
wire.com Knowles use code Knowles at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign